- [Voiceover] Which picture
divides a rectangle in half?
So to divide something in half we need to
divide it into two equal sections.
Over here we're divided into two sections
but these aren't equal.
These don't have the same area.
This part has a much
larger area than this one.
So this isn't divided in half.
This one's also divided into two sections
but they're not equal.
This one is much bigger than this one.
This is divided into equal sections,
but it's not two equal sections.
This is divided into three equal sections,
so this isn't divided in half.
Here we're divided into
two equal sections.
One, two sections, and they
are the same size, the same area.
So I'd pick that one.
Let's keep going. This is a lot of fun.
Which picture divides
a circle into halves?
Once again, two equal sections.
This one, this one, and this one divide
into three sections,
and actually these two
right over here, the three
sections aren't even equal.
Then here, this is three equal sections
but that would be thirds not halves.
Halves would be two equal sections,
so it'll be that, right over there.
Which picture divides
a square into fourths
or sometimes people might say
divides a square into quarters.
Well fourths or quarters
would be four equal sections.
Well this is two equal sections.
This is one section,
this is just one whole.
This is two equal
sections, right over here.
Or I guess you could say this one
actually is just not divided at all.
This right over here
is two equal sections.
This is four equal sections,
so this is fourths,
or you could say this is
divided into quarters.
Let's keep going.
Let's do a few more of these.
Which picture divides a circle in half?
So this circle isn't divided.
This is a circle divided into
thirds, three equal sections.
This is a circle divided into two pieces,
but they're not equal, so this
isn't divided into halves.
This is two equal
sections, right over here,
so that one is halves.
Let's do one more.
Which picture divides a
rectangle into halves?
Well, it has to be two equal sections.
This is three equal sections.
This is three not even equal sections.
This is three equal sections,
so this would be thirds,
just as this one would be thirds.
This one over here is two equal sections,
so that is halves.